dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly Jonah if I hear this
one is going to be huge certainly one of
my favorites this work is a combination
of several techniques that we have
talked about earlier if you don't know
some of these terms it's perfectly okay
you can remedy this by clicking on the
pop-ups or checking the description box
but you'll get the idea even watching
only this episode so first we have a
convolutional neural network
this helps processing images and
understanding what is depicted on an
image and a reinforcement learning
algorithm this helps creating strategies
or to be more exact it decides what the
next action we make should be what
buttons we push on a joystick so this
technique mixes together these two
concepts and we call it deep cue
learning and it is able to learn to play
games the same way as a human would it
is not exposed to any additional
information in the code all it sees is
the screen and the current score when it
starts learning to play an old game
Atari breakout at first the algorithm
loses all of its lives without any signs
of intelligent action
if we wait a bit it becomes better at
playing the game roughly matching the
skill level of an adept player
but here's the catch if we wait for
longer we get something absolutely
spectacular it finds out that the best
way to win the game is digging a tunnel
through the bricks and hit them from
behind
I really didn't know this and this is an
incredible moment I can use my computer
this box next to me that is able to
create new knowledge find out new things
I haven't known before this is
completely absurd science fiction is not
the future it is already here
it also plays many other games the
percentages show the relation of the
game scores compared to a human player
above 70% means it's great and above
100% its superhuman as a follow-up work
scientists at deep mind started
experimenting with 3d games and after a
few days of training it could learn to
drive on idea racing lines and pass
others with ease I've had my driving
license for a while now but I still
don't always get the idea racing lines
right Bravo I have heard the complaint
that this is not real intelligence
because it doesn't know the concept of a
ball or what it is exactly doing let's
get Dijkstra once said the question of
whether machines can think is about as
relevant as the question of whether
submarines can swim beyond the fact that
rigorously defining intelligence leans
more into the domain of philosophy than
science I'd like to add that I am
perfectly happy with effective
algorithms we use these techniques to
accomplish different tasks and they are
really good problem solvers in the
breakout game you as a person learn the
concept of a ball in order to be able to
use this knowledge as a machinery to
perform better if this is not the case
whoever knows a lot but can't use it to
achieve anything useful is not an
intelligent being but an encyclopedia
what about the future there are two
major unexplored directions the
algorithm doesn't have long term memory
and even if it had it wouldn't be able
to generalize its knowledge to other
similar tasks super exciting directions
for future work thanks for watching and
for your generous support and I'll see
you next time